[Applause]
what is ayahuasca ayahuasca ultimately
is a two ingredient tea
so it's a it's a vine known as ayahuasca
and then a leaf with
called chacona cooked like a tea so it's
a two-ingredient tea
okay so the question is is how come
we drink this tea without regard and
then we're scared of this tea
yes you know ultimately it's tea so
therefore it's a medicine like
shamanism plants are medicine and
chemicals and drugs so drugs can be used
medicinally
and plants can be used as drugs
tulum right burning yeah yeah
you know yeah shaman's everywhere yeah
so
you know people running around just like
oh you want to try you know so that's
the problem but
if you use things ceremonially medicines
yes you're gonna have every single time
the results that
that you described like the
transformation that's where the healing
occurs
you know because ultimately if you want
to say like what is ayahuasca on the
grants the macro
if you look at if you triangulate
everything shamanically
we say mother earth correct mother earth
yeah right the earth mother because it
brings life on the earth yeah but to the
earth it's the child of earth
father son mother moon everything is
alchemically combined between masculine
and feminine principles
to exist so the earth is comprised of
three
um three kingdoms the plant mineral and
the animal kingdom
the mineral kingdom is father nature the
deserts the mountains
the plant kingdom is mother nature and
then the children of earth the animal
kingdom
and so when we talk about the earth
the amazon is the womb of the earth
it's five percent of the earth land mass
but produces 20
of all the ocean all of the air over all
the land
and all the ocean so inside the womb of
mother nature
grows a vine called ayahuasca and so
ayahuasca is just the name
for the spirit of mother nature in the
language of shapibo
from the amazon so in christian
mysticism they refer to mother nature's
spirit as gaia
in islam they say they say ariana
the greeks called it sophia and so
in the amazon they called ayahuasca the
difference is
you can meet her so you can
meet mother nature through ayahuasca now
it is the same thing
oh when you use it that is the
experience that's mother nature okay
mother nature is going to take you
and take your baby soul and swallow you
again like this
and start at the beginning okay okay now
i want to get into that
can you break down chemically what it is
sure what
what is this is it dmt is it like acid
like is it is it yeah
more extreme mushrooms like what what is
happening to me when i take this thing
so
ayahuasca itself has no dmt um
dmt is added in a leaf called chakruna
this is it
yeah that's the thing about dmt is it
was oh smoking dmt
smoking you know smoking dmt is one
thing but dmt is naturally found in
every single plant that's green on the
earth
every single plant on the earth your
salad has
is all dmt okay right we have dmt in our
cerebral spinal fluid our third eye our
pineal gland secretes dmt as well as
absorbs dmt
so if you were to smoke dmt or drink
ayahuasca that's the first time that
your third eye is going to be fed
so it's like you want to know how you're
supposed to operate
feed the third eye and you'll see your
full capacity and capabilities
as a as a human right but um
dmt is not the point of ayahuasca that
otherwise
the the medicine would be called
chakruna it wouldn't be called ayahuasca
ayahuasca
has no dmt dmt is added because as
humans of our five sensorial
three-dimensional reality the the
perception that we rely on the most is
the sense of sight
how do you know because you saw
something right and so
dmt is added so that way mother yawaska
has
a 10d com you know
screen to teach you through okay so
you can learn in the jungle they don't
put much
chikuna leaves there's not much dmt in
their medicines
it's because they're already naturally
connected they live in the freaking
amazon
they're like living under trees you know
here we grow up in like new york miami
you know we're like real so we need to
make sure for the medicine to work here
that large amounts of dnt is added into
the medicine
oh this is so this is interesting so
they can access the same connectivity
with mother nature through mainly just
using the ayahuasca plan
yeah and it's almost like how chinese
food is is changed over here in the west
to like fit
our palate yes like there's a
general sews version of ayahuasca that
westerners are using because we are so
disconnected from mother mother
nature that the chakruna has to create
that connectivity
visually for us because we don't want
trust that instinctual connection we're
just we just have so many different
walls
uh both in like you know the the chakra
system which is basically like energy
fields within the body like yeah
we don't even believe in these things a
lot of ways we have no idea okay we
don't even know that we don't know
that's the problem with our societies we
we are operating on an unconscious
incompetent level but yet we think we
have all the answers
okay so so at your stage right now and i
do want to get back into this but at
your stage right now could you take
pure ayahuasca and access the same
connectivity
you mean just the ayahuasca vine yeah no
water without any
yeah 100 and is that something that
you'll do for more experienced
ayahuasca practitioners
so the thing is people no actually you
would that would be for
yes if the more experienced you are the
more
you have a familiarity with uh with
the presence and the energy and the
spirit and then your your own soul
in the dimension it would it would be
like going in
to a specific type of pool with a
specific type of wave
you know like your familiar hot tub of
the soul
as opposed to some random one at the the
one hotel
you know ain't trashy uh you know going
to a dirty
bathtub you know this is like a clean
nice
you know uh private one but yeah the
thing is
is that with with ayahuasca's is um
so the human body was created whether
you think we were created by god from
the garden
or the annunaki doesn't matter but at
the end of the day the human body was
created with
with them with all of the tools and all
of the system completely open
but we were created with certain
barriers so humans are the only animal
that
walks on this earth that cannot eat
green leaves and digest
and metabolize dmt so that's why we
don't live symbiotically on earth
so in ancient egypt they said that the
key to the soul lies in the liver
and so ultimately what ayahuasca does
chemically
and biologically within us is that when
we
drink the ayahuasca the ayahuasca
produces an maoi
and so the maoi stops mao mono monoxide
inhibitors basically
when we eat dmt our liver produces an
enzyme that stops us from digesting the
dmt
naturally right so whoever our creator
was
stopped i wanted life to be a little
more boring eat from the tree of life
never touch the tree of knowledge of
good and evil and if you do
we're going to make sure that there's
it's a barrier on top of that
we're going to have two locks on the
door in case you find one key
you know so that's what we're dealing
with ultimately and what would be the
advantage of that for a species
control wouldn't you want a slave race
to stay asleep
why do we wear masks after you have the
vaccine yeah
i
it's all it's all magic that's the thing
it's all it's all a battle between good
and evil
light and dark and there's sheeps and
wolves right okay that's that's the
ultimate truth but
so so in essence when we drink the
ayahuasca chemically the ayahuasca has
an maoi
so it puts a layer and stops the liver
from
from from basically disintegrating the
dmt allowing for the dmt
to metabolize go into the bloodstream
and then feed the third eye
that's what we're dealing with here and
so then
you know it's just the real [ __ ] starts
to happen
system go yeah yeah yeah so can you
can you break down like what starts to
happen in that experience
um and i imagine it's different for
every every person
but like or maybe speak on your first
time taking it because i've heard all
these different things like people
it almost feels as if and please give me
pushback if if i'm wrong here but like
that it's a form of like dealing with
childhood trauma a lot of people that
i've heard
take it or that have took it were kind
of like went into it with a problem with
their dad
or they were you know maybe molested or
something as a kid
like maybe they had like maybe they
aborted a child that they felt all awful
about abortion and then like
they said that they were processing
these things and working through these
relationships in the trip
and the trip did not seem fun at all
yeah
so this idea for for like the casual
drug user is like yeah i'm gonna do acid
one day i'm gonna do mushrooms one day
i'm gonna do ayahuasca
yeah i don't i don't know if i would
place it in that
same realm no no ayahuasca is in his own
dimension of everything
and everything you mentioned those are
good reasons to drink ayahuasca or
or then you know like dealer they have
childhood trauma and then they turn to
drugs and alcohol as a way to fix that
so they have compounding
things and there's a source issue but
regardless of anything that
ultimately the mind-blowing part of it
is is that you think you're going to
drink ayahuasca for abc
right but there's a you know words have
a lot of meaning right so there's like
you know i'm coming here for this but
there's like
beneath the surface you know like if
if we are if one thing that all
religions and spiritualities teach us is
that the soul is eternal right so they
say that at one point we were created by
something
and we've existed and will continue to
exist forever that's why people are
afraid of
heaven and hell because they know
they're going to continue to exist how
you know the churches will tell you yeah
you know
for a fee everyone's got an answer for
you everyone's got an answer for you
right everyone will tell you what's
going to happen to you next
but yet everyone's living in fear right
so the thing is is that
that's why it's called getting to the
root of the problem okay
so it's like there's a there's there's
the beginning of everything right and so
ayahuasca has this way of
sure dealing with childhood traumas all
these things getting to the source of
things but going deeper than
you know into like the highest depths
like places that
within yourself that you know to be real
because
you know inside they're real like you
probably experienced in your burning man
journey you just described right
going to like senses of knowingness that
you may not be able to even
verbally describe but they are
experiences that
change you and create a wider platform
on the
on the on you know this being that you
call
andrew to have an experience from right
is it possible that some people can't
handle
that no well it's possible of course but
that's why you have a shaman
otherwise you should just go get
ayahuasca and drink it in your condo
you